Angel: Hi, YouTube. This is Angel Gurria,
Secretary-General of the Organization for
Economic Co-operation and Development the
OECE.
[Pause]
>> Ok, so the question is do you feel that
the environment will lose out to the economy
in 2009.
Angel: The environment should not, must not,
and I'm doing everything that I can so that
it will not lose to the recession, to the
economy.
There are some things we have to tackle immediately.
We have to tackle the banks, the stability.
They have to lend again those packages of
stimulus in order to get the economy working
again.
But we cannot forget the medium and the long
term issues.
The climate change, the poverty, the [inaudible]
round, we have to close that.
And by the way, we may be in better shape
than we think, because many of these stimulus
packages have a big content that is supposed
to be a green.
That creates jobs, but also green jobs, green
investments.
So we should make sure that the green content
is as much as we can get in it.